[Applause]
[Music]
Boswell said category celebra Lamia film
it jorge de l'année mmm what Helen said
was yo my oscar-winning performance as a
queen was much more realistic than
calling first as a king
janay padishah gracel to a an idiot oh
I'm very flattered Dame Helen but I am
of course married now here are the
nominees for Best Foreign Language Film
from Mexico beautiful Alejandro Gonzalez
Inarritu
from Greece doctor jurgis LAN Tomas from
Denmark in a better world
Susannah beer from Canada on Sandy Denny
Ville nerve from Algeria outside the law
OhLaLa Rashid
Bouchard
and the Oscar goes to
in a better world and then my Susannah
beer
[Music]
is the third movie from Denmark to win
the Academy Award for foreign language
film
oh my god M this is this is a real Oscar
Morpha Ellison gargy well this is thank
you so much the Academy what in what an
honor
I am so truly honored and grateful and
happy thank you very much I really need
to congratulate my fellow nominees who
movies were amazing and I really want to
thank Tom Bennett and Michael Varga at
Sony classics for believing so strongly
in a better world all my all my creative
partners whether they are in this room
or in Denmark or Sweden this one belongs
to all of you as much as it belongs to
me thank you very much ladies job I come